this next speaker as a repeat and we
always like to ask speakers what they a
little fun fact about themselves and his
fun fact is he ran out of fun facts
so with that everyone please welcome
Emil I'm very happy to be here this is
uh taught up in very excited to talk
about I like to think about this topic
as what I do am I supposed to do other
things
so
I'm sure some people in here wouldn't
want to hear that
so uh oh no
it wasn't supposed to happen all right
so while we wait for this to work I'm
gonna do some disclaimers
when you spend time writing on meeting
your slides prettier for some definition
of prettier
it can end up taking all the time you
have
so my rule of thumb is
I said a predefined time of
fixing the aesthetic of a slide and then
when I'm done with that I don't spend
more time on it so if I had two days to
do one day of meeting them pretty and
then one day of filling in the content
so then you just use it it and it's the
concept switching kind of thing
I'm also not trying to pretend like I
don't know anything about how to make
things pretty but I know how to change
their status of slides in Toronto
and that's what I'll show now I don't
try to at all say I know what I'm doing
all right let's try again one more time
all right nice all right so I'll be
talking about what I like to call slide
drafting which is uh doing fun things
with slides
all right so before we need to talk
about what is quarto so throttle is this
a new open source scientific and Tech at
all publishing system built in paintball
it is this new thing from passive last
year
we like announced it and
everybody here I assume know I've heard
about Ahmad down and Toro is
I like to think of the technical like
the spiritual successor to Ahmad down
except that now it works
independent from us so you also have
support for python Julia observable and
it has room to improve later it's like
built on
so you don't need eye installed anymore
but if you want to you can use it with
her and yeah it's like
many many years of armada development
has been distilled into tottoro so they
learn for another States and now
everything fits more uniformly into one
package
and it words to say by the way you would
expect so here we have like a 18 years
old Jupiter note Birds to do python
things you can
use it how you would arm up down is a
little bit different since it has white
space mostly the same
you can also use lit Julia or observable
so and I assume that a lot of scripting
languages will that support in the
future
so if you're already familiar with us
I'm up down I want taught about it Dan
will talk a little bit about about
portal so I want to intimate the details
what I will talk about is one of the
formats that come out of throttle is
this reveal.js so this is a framework of
trade in presentations slide there are
HTML slides
and these types of slides are
reminiscent of like the syringe like
remark JS slides that we use to make
that's some subtle differences on Sims
head and how actually everything works
but it's the same idea you create
basically a website and this is what I'm
using right now
so um it was like how loud we have up
here we have on the left we have yes
left left we have
a total document which is a glorified my
time document so we have a yaml at the
top with information and then we
do light headers to differentiate the
slide so uh
level 2 header which is a two hashtags
is a new slide one is a section so I
tend to use the two
so we have like a title and then
each slide just watch how you would
expect with that done so
like bullet like you can do like the
little light you can bold things how you
how you expect them to bowl you can
create a list the same way you do too
and how we expect from Ahmad down if you
add third chance the
the third will be evaluated and be
posted into the slides right away
is that anything we'll be talking about
how reveal J is word
uh
in intelligent Basics they have a great
intro page of all the functionality and
I'm just gonna point out some of the
things that I can need and some of the
things that aren't documented
so we have uh we net columns so we have
these um
they are like a fenced deaths so when
you add these like triple tolerance they
create a div in HTML
and if you add like a thing after it
like here's this column so that will
dead at last columns and then you can
Nest them how you want so here we have a
pedal div tall Talons and an inside then
we have two divs each name each of the
class column and they have their width
set to 50 so you get 50 50 columns and
you can do whatever this is less
flexible you can add four columns that
all has waves that add up to 100 or less
than 100 they need to have spaces and
stuff
you can add um
images like absolute so you put in an
image like how you normally would and
then add the class absolute and then
with like top left right order strings
and sizes you can
um precisely put in an image where you
want it to be you don't have to try to
make things work
one thing that isn't documented at all
is if you live at
a whole Slide the class Center
it will send out a tant and
vertically
which is normally the super hard to do
but you have like these little things
that sends it verbally
and it's really like I think it's neat
is hard to use otherwise
and then another thing is if you just
want the biggest test possible you use
the class R Dash fit test and it will
just make it as big as it tanned within
the container
so that is what's a very fast way to
just make slices all like fit test
everywhere in the deadlite nice bit
slides
all right so it's just like the basis a
little bit of how to do different things
there's a lot more information on the
website
so the first thing when I want to like
change this statement of my slides is I
want to deal with a thousand fonts and
untried basic so I end up on Pinterest
and you can just search Tyler palettes
and a bunch of things time up and it's
all like different you can search like
the beach theme it's all beach pictures
with like little palettes on them
everywhere you might have some
inspiration you have some pictures you
have something that inspires you you use
the eyedropper tool and pick out a
certain number of dollars
you don't necessarily want to throw like
two overboard and you need like I feel
like you need two to at most five
dollars so you need a background color a
test teller and then you have a ton of
AdSense
um
you just need to make sure that these
colors work well together so you need to
make sure that your background and that
you're attached is visible when people
don't have your computer right there so
you just search like a Teletubbies
chatter you can put in some toilets and
will tell you how legible is detached
and annoyingly it also depends on font
size so you can't just use the best
number you need to also learn is this
gonna be like body test or like titles
and then we'll find you can use any type
of font you want I end up using doodle
files a lot because you just used a
little import statement and I'll show
how to do that later
and but you just use local like like
local files as files you have a really
fancy font or a homemade font uh I have
a blog post that is linked at the end
showing you how to use any font at all
so you can like do really fun things so
just finding files also just brutal
Finance way to tell like I don't
I end up stealing other people's Farms
because I don't know enough about
pitting good ones
all right so
these basic characteristics of how your
slide Works uh
driven by these things tall SAS
variables and also how to set them in a
moment but at the documentation of the
little Link at the bottom of the slide
we have these variable names and they're
fairly like uh
like intuitive names here a background
color and a body taller and Light
defined families of like presentations
and other things so you find what you
want to change and then you set that
variable
so we're showing that right here so add
your you in your uh
your Marathon file you specify in the
yaml saying Hey I want to add
um some CSS and here is technically
using like a SAS and scss so it's like a
supercharged SSS that allows us to do
logic and like more easily variable
passing
and then yeah so we have again our
Styles like ruler
like this so here it Imports
input statement that came in that we
started from brutal and then we just say
hey I want the
the font family of the sensors
description test we want the
presentation size but the text size of
everything to be fairly bad because all
I should hand read it
and it needs to be it's better than you
think like you can't do 20 you need to
do like a fairly big number and it will
depend on your file you choose and we
can say oh I always want to save the
link color so that is
so you just want to see it's a link
toilet and some of these variables are
used throughout
so you could say and it does it already
like you have the link color and you can
reuse this link over here
and we want to emit it 25 lighter so
that is the slide hierarchy of light you
shouldn't specify everything at the top
and everything just like flows through
so you see now it looks light
uh State a different font the link tell
us this difference either
link first and we can also let's say oh
if you change the background color we
now have a new background to unlock
everything
all right so the way I end up doing all
my slides is at the very top of my CSS
file
I write I trade a bunch of variables and
I'll all theme and then a taller name
and then I'll just pick the colors I'm
using and then I can use those color
names later
so I only so each
holler or name
is only really for gonna be used once
because if I decide this blue isn't
really light like leaving what I need
you can change it once and everything
flows through
and here's some slides here where you
can then like anything what what else to
do with my Travelers is I create these
custom CSS classes at the very bottom
you see has dark blue and it's the color
is my theme blue
and then I use that in like my slider if
I want to do some highlighting that's
other than folding and making fixer
tablets I can just say hey make this
word blue or make this area teal and it
works
and this isn't necessarily you can also
like you can also make these custom
classes to make things bold you can make
things a specific font I like fonts like
style if you want to have a lighter a
wavy font to like show something scary
or something you didn't have like a a
starry tat and it just like you didn't
use it
um
this particular very manual over time
and what I do
if I really feel like I want to do
something kind of neat
is I spent my time in my uh
CSS and I write these
like themes that are like slide specific
so I'm saying on this slide I want a
background to be this I want you to have
this one tell us what have these font
sizes
if you used a Serenity inverse
theme where you just put inverse and
then instead of being white or flat sets
that's black with white test but you can
let it expand that however you want so a
little bit how in PowerPoint you have
like a template where you say oh I want
to now add a thing that has like test of
one side and image on the other side
that's what I'm doing here in uh in CSS
so then when I'm writing my slides I
don't really use much theming
when I write the slides I just add the
theme
type I want for each of the slide see
that let's slice that look like this
so now like
it's just not everything that this is uh
the background is just the SVG that has
a little animation in it but it also
sell it here like there's a bit old
globe on the right hand side and the CSS
knows that and is restricting the area
where the test will happen so you don't
have to do it manually every time you
set everything up front and then you
just write your slides real fast
and a lot of these must be made to like
be re-share so like you trade it once
you trade your your torque slide that
has all the colors you need it has
slightly different like type of slide
you write it once and then you use that
every time moving forward
all right
another thing what this is a little bit
hard for me so another thing that I
don't like about the real slide is the
weighted content is so the pattern just
those fills the screen no matter the
size of the screen so if you put in an
image in the background and your
presentation Dimensions is different
than your computer Dimensions it might
overlap with test because
the background isn't absolute it's based
on the dimensions of the slide so I
wrote this a Toro extension
so this is like a it's basically
reveal.js slide but they behave uh how
like syringe in dead wear light
the slide content is always fixed in
space and then it just adds like a
background color on the side
and this makes it look really easy to do
something where you want an image that
always takes up half
so here
that the test will always be like the
same compared to the images
that is not something you can do in a
normal reveal.js slides because of the
way positioning everything works
um one thing to add a little bit of
light passage to your slices this video
fragments so this is you're specifying
what needs to happen and these fragments
happens
um one by one so you say it's a fragment
it defaults to like fading in so when we
go forward it
the Texas has fade in fades in then the
next one will be net sort of thing it
says Fade Out it will fade out and the
things that says highlight red will
highlight red
but we can also trade our own fragments
so it comes from 20 different ones but
we might want to do something a little
bit more fun so um this is like the
template of how it works so you just
type this in and change the blue part to
the name of what you want to tell your
fragment
and then you fill in the blanks
so here in this specific one I want to
say it needs to just look normal to
begin with but then when it becomes
visible
it needs to have a background color of
orange
so this means that when you have a new
slide that you can do light
um
that you're highlighting which I feel
that this is more highlighting than like
changing the color
so we have like oh we're highlighting
things it's it's a little bit neat
where things become a little bit more
fun I think is
um this is just a HTML page
that does some fancy things and right
now in this page it has a JavaScript
object
that is like what
the slides are
so it is like reveal object has a lot of
information about the slide and is used
to modify so if either into the tonsil
and press reveal dot left
it will do better slide or at the photo
slide I think that light how fine
everyone slides and find out all these
information about the slide or let's do
things about it I can Shuffle the slides
which is kind of fun
what it has is this event listeners so
every time like the first one
every toad that is inside this like
parenthesis that says
slide changed is run every time a slide
is changed
or you can run some arbitrary JavaScript
code every time the window is resized
so if there's some things you can do if
you know enough jars if you can do
anything you want as a Twitter whenever
a slide is changed
what I found that what I want to spend
time moving forward working on is
this idea fragment shown and fragment
hidden so every time
a fragment is shown you can also mod it
can also tall arbitrary JavaScript code
so
um and that's actually what I've been
doing to do the whenever I press forward
the embedded slide that moves forward
so I I added a advanced slide
fragment
and
every time it goes forward it
uses some JavaScript to find the iframe
and Advance it
and it also works backwards also have it
moving back to it so when I hide it so
if I do bat and fourth the the slides
inside wet with me
and didn't do more fun things with this
so this is like maybe not the it's a way
of like hiding things but you can add
like Trader custom animations in like
JavaScript when you click something
something unfolds so you can do a lot of
things you can change
things that might not you might not be
able to do in JavaScript in in with CSS
is not deal with JavaScript so this is
where life becomes really hard for
someone like me because I have a real
job and I can't spend my time just
writing slides all the time
all right so this is how like this
basically how it looked when I did the
thing I put in my iframe and then I just
add these Advanced slides underneath and
then forward and that's how we advance
everything
all right that's all I have I wrote a
a very stagnant blog post Series where I
try to turn down some of these points
and I'm trying to add Atmos if you're
interested
find me I'm immediate foot everywhere so
I'm easy to find
foreign